ville américaine mais pour la perdre le
grand lac salé qui lui a donné son nom
c'est le plus grand lac salé d'Amérique
du Nord il pourrait s'assécher
complètement d'ici 5 ans c'est ce qu'on
voit dans un des rapports très récents
c'est l'une des nouvelles qu'on va
aborder à notre chronique environnement
avec Renaud Manuguerra gagné qui est
avec nous donc ce matin bonjour bonjour
bonne année 2023 à moins que je l'ai
déjà fait je l'ai fait
jamais trop on parle d'une situation qui
est critique de ce grand là moi
effectivement parce que selon la
trentaine de chercheurs qui ont rédigé
les rapports c'est en fait c'est surtout
la surconsommation d'eau qui est la
cause de ce problème il faut rappeler
que ça fait des décennies que le Grand
Lac Salé donc de l'Utah est en déclin
depuis 1850 donc la construction de
barrage le pompage de l'eau ça fait
perdre au lac soit 73% de son eau et 60%
de sa surface on le voit à l'image
d'ailleurs un comparatif
en 1985 et on le voit après ça en 2022
donc on voit toutes les conséquences de
cette surconsommation d'eau aujourd'hui
encore il y a plus de 3000 billions de
litres d'eau qui sont détournés des
affluents du lac chaque année par les
différents états qui sont autour de la
région 75 % de cette eau-là pour
l'agriculture donc on comprend que c'est
important mais éventuellement il y a un
point il y a un point limite qui va être
atteint donc le niveau du lac est
maintenant 4 mètres en dessous de ce qui
est considéré comme le seuil minimal
pour qu'il soit viable et bon
le il est selon les chercheurs si le
niveau la consommation d'eau elle est
pas réduite du tiers à la moitié au
cours de la période 2023 2024 mais cela
clope pourrait disparaître d'ici les
cinq prochaines années bon donc je
comprends que ça va être très très grave
comme conséquence si le lac disparaît
quoi c'est l'eau potable qu'on va puiser
là aussi l'eau potable va continuer
d'être pris des affluents mais ça a
beaucoup le problème vient surtout de ce
qui est au fond du lac en fait il y a
trois problèmes le premier
environnemental donc c'est un lac est un
écosystème pour des milliards d'animaux
qui disparaître ou devoir s'en aller si
et plus là le lac aussi c'est un
important régulateur du climat de la
région donc si François en désert de sel
ça faisait moins de pluie moins de neige
pour les pour la région mais la
conséquence la plus sournoise au niveau
de la santé humaine parce qu'on parle
d'un lac salé si ça sèche une croûte de
sel ou sur le lit de la claque qui va
être exposé à l'air c'est celle-là
contient aussi des producteurs de
l'arsenic des métaux lourds comme du
mercure et ça se transforme très
facilement en poussière toxique qui
pourrait affecter la santé des milliers
des millions d'habitants de la région et
des études qui ont été faites en
Californie sur d'autres lacs salés que
ce sont asséchés par le passé qui ont
montré que ces sites-là devient
d'importants générateurs de poussière
toxiques qui augmentent les niveaux
d'asthme de maladie cardiovasculaires de
maladies pulmonaires les habitants de la
région donc c'est pas encore trop tard
pour les habitants de Salt Lake City
mais faut que les responsables de l'État
fassent quelque chose rapidement sinon
on va se lancer avec une bombe
environnementale qui va exploser au
visage de plein-temps parce que l'eau là
on a l'air à penser que c'était éternel
un an si on en consomme ça revient pas
tout seul d'ailleurs il y a
l'exploitation illégal qui mine la
qualité de plusieurs rivières ça c'est
un autre rapport qui l'indiquait c'est
une autre étude qui est parue cette
semaine c'est des chercheurs américains
qui ont fait le suivi de l'impact
environnemental d'exploitation minière
illégale dans 49 pays au niveau de
l'équateur donc on parle on parle aussi
de petites exploitations artisanales
donc imaginez quelques des villageois
qui vont des outils de fortune sur la
dans la rivière essaie d'extraire des
métaux rares ou des cartels plus
organisés une dizaine d'hommes qui vont
faire des opérations là ces opérations
qui sont très polluantes parce qu'on
utilise des produits toxiques souvent du
mercure pour extraire les métaux rares
de l'eau et ensuite on rejette tout ça
dans l'eau c'est un problème
environnemental c'est un problème pour
les gens qui boivent ce taux le plus
loin et c'est ces exploitations là sont
difficiles à trouver parce qu'elles sont
souvent dans des régions tropicales dans
ces moments peuplées mais en utilisant
une nouvelle méthode d'imagerie et
d'analyse mais aller chercheurs
américains ont développé une méthode
pour retracer plus facilement ses
activités ces exploitations là ils ont
trouvé 386 dans leur étude du seulement
des sites qui étaient pas connus et ils
ont même entendu depuis 1980 le taux de
débris de mercure doublé dans 80% des
rivières que eux ont observé ça ça
représente 7% des grandes rivières
tropicales du monde donc c'est beaucoup
d'eau qui est contaminé au mercure et
donc ces chercheurs-là espèrent que leur
étude va tirer l'attention sur les
exploitations minières illégales parce
que ces conséquences moins comme la plus
grande source de contamination mercure
dans le monde waouh quand même
incroyable tous ces nouvelles sur l'eau
d'un seul coup tout ce qui est publié
très bien même merci beaucoup
au revoir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI